[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
und marietta slomka guten abend würde
man hierzulande eine straßenumfrage
machen und fragen wie der aktuelle
russische oder amerikanische botschafter
in berlin heißt viele hätten da wohl
nicht sofort einen namen parat aber
andrej melik den kennt man als
botschafter der ukraine ist er im zuge
des angriffs auf sein land zu einer
prominenz gelangt wie sieht diplomaten
nur selten erringen das lag auch daran
dass melnik nicht wie ein klassischer
diplomat auftrag einerseits hat er damit
viel erreicht die deutsche regierung
angetrieben floskeln entlarvt
andererseits hat er auch viele vor den
kopf gestoßen und sich mit äußerungen
angreifbar gemacht heute nun die meldung
dass kiew ihn von seinem posten
abberufen hat
theo koll das kommt ja nicht ganz
überraschend ja das kann man so sagen
und zwar in unterschiedlichen
abstufungen ich glaube führenden
vertretern der berliner politik wurde so
höre ich jedenfalls schon vor wochen
angedeutet dass es zu einem botschafter
wechsel kommen könne in den vergangenen
tagen gab es dann noch erste
pressespekulationen die allerdings nie
offiziell bestätigt wurden bis zum
heutigen dekret des ukrainischen
präsidenten und was hört man in berlin
was dahinter steckt
na ja formal könnte man es einen
normalen vorgang den magic war ja für
ein botschafter schon fast doppelt so
lange in berlin wie sonst üblich und mit
ihm werden auch viele andere ukrainische
botschafter abgesetzt das hat auch der
ukrainische präsident heute abend noch
einmal betont aber eine reihe von
faktoren spricht gegen eine normale
abberufung malick hatte ja zuletzt einen
führenden radikalen und antisemitischen
nationalisten aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
stepan bandera verharmlost was zu
scharfen reaktionen aus polen und aus
israel führte und das wasser auf die
mühlen der russischen propaganda war die
ja seit langem behauptet man kämpfe in
der ukraine gegen nazis und zudem dürfte
sich in kiew auch der blick auf mehr
diplomatische art verändert haben
anfangs hat seine harsche kritik an der
deutschen zögerlichkeit durchaus
politisch und publizistisch etwas
bewirkt aber nach dem externe immer
schriller wurden hat ja beispielsweise
den kanzler als eine beleidigte
leberwurst bezeichnet dürfte sich die
regierung in kiew auch die frage
gestellt haben ob der sagen wir mal
angerichtete schaden durch den
streitbaren und diplomaten nicht langsam
größer wird als der nutzen ich glaube
seine abberufung ist die antwort darauf
dankeschön für die einschätzung
derweil nutzte annalena baerbock heute
die gelegenheit die aufmerksamkeit auf
ein anderes thema als den in europa
alles beherrschenden krieg zu lenken vom
g20-treffen auf bali reiste sie weiter
nach palau der inselstaat mit hunderten
inseln liegt im westpazifik in
mikronesien ein weltnaturerbe
doch die folgen des klimawandels sehen
die bewohner von palau bereits jeden tag
und heute sahen sie eine deutsche
außenministerin barfuß am strand die
dieses welt thema in ihrer amtszeit
eigentlich viel stärker in den
vordergrund rücken wollte als sie das in
den letzten monaten möglich war andreas
künast berichtet
sein ganzes leben hat leon auf palo
verbracht er kann das meer und den
strand sehen denn heute eine deutsche
ministeriums delegation abschreitet und
ab filmt leon filmt die deutschen die
seine steine filmen die er
aufgeschichtet hat weil das meer jahr
für jahr näher kommt
die steine sind zu klein wir bräuchten
eine große barriere damit die wellen
daran gehindert werden den sand
hinauszutragen ins meer
am strand vor leons haus steht annalena
baerbock der erste deutsche minister
besuch auf palau seit 120 jahren
wahrscheinlich so haben die
einheimischen ausgerechnet würde bei
einer erderwärmung von 1,5 grad geradeso
überleben aber sind die 1,5 grad noch zu
schaffen die 19.000 einwohner palaus
schlagen seit jahren alarm schicken
abordnungen auf jede klimakonferenz
liefern zahlen kurven unwiderlegbare
fakten
aber ich muss zugeben dass unsere
internationale reaktion unzureichend war
unsere unterstützung zu begrenzt
heute sagt berbalk palau unterstützung
zu beim ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
damit die inseln keine
diesel-generatoren mehr brauchen wie
viele jahre herr gouverneur werden noch
bleiben
das ist eine sehr gute frage wir hoffen
dass wir mit guten wissenschaftlern
zusammenarbeiten und dass sie uns ein
weiteres jahrhundert geben
es gehört zum alltag einer grünen
außenministerin dass sie jede reise und
erst recht diese super fernreise
verteidigen muss warum darf man im namen
des klimaschutzes ans andere ende der
welt fliegen
das kann man theoretisch in der zeitung
lesen aber wenn man es vor ort mit
eigenen augen sieht wenn man auf solchen
delegationsreisen auch viele
journalisten
andere akteure aus dem parlament zur
parlamentarier mitbringt dann wird diese
nachricht hoffentlich auch weiter
verbreitet weil hier wird deutlich die
zeit läuft uns davon die zeit die noch
bleibt ist ungleich verteilt palau hat
weniger davon übrig als deutschland
kommen wir zu einem wirtschaftsthema das
heute wieder weltweit für schlagzeilen
sorgt und seit geraumer zeit fast schon
kuriose züge annimmt die eigentümliche
aktion ich kaufe twitter oder doch nicht
des tech milliardär cinaz der mann
exzentrisch ist weiß man inzwischen
zugleich ruhen auf ihm viele hoffnungen
nicht nur im deutschen brandenburg
warum er unbedingt twitter übernehmen
wollte zu einem horrenden preis darüber
ist schon viel spekuliert worden hatte
er politische beweggründe und warum
schadete er dann mit abfälligen
äußerungen dem unternehmen für das er
bereits seinen kaufvertrag
unterschrieben hatte von dem ist er
jetzt auch offiziell zurückgetreten an
erfasst berichtet
börsenschluss auf der wall street
freitagabend womöglich war es kalkül
dass elon musk absage an twitter erst
danach öffentlich wird denn schon im
nachbörslichen handel fallen die twitter
aktien um 6 prozent das wird ein domino
effekt auslösen
es war von anfang an eine seifenoper und
was im april mit dem 44 milliarden
dollar angebot begann endet jetzt in
einem zwielichtigen moment in dem masse
von bord geht
die seiten europa in kurzfassung ende
märz maske will seine eigene social
media plattform tage später wird er
twitter ist größter aktionär und startet
dann ein übernahmeversuch twitter wehrt
sich zunächst ende april dann die
einigung mit vertragsunterzeichnung elon
musk kauft wird dafür 44 milliarden
dollar also 54 dollar pro aktie zwei
wochen später zieht mast plötzlich die
bremse er wurde von twitter mehr daten
zur spam und fake nutzer konnten und nun
der große knall masse erklärt den kauf
für aufgelöst was steckt dahinter
ihm wurde wohl klar dass jetzt so viel
für das unternehmen bezahlt hat 54
dollar pro aktie sind einfach zu viel
also suchte er nach ausreden um da
rauszukommen und wird er damit vor
gericht durchkommen höchst
unwahrscheinlich dass ein gericht
entscheidet dass er von einem
unterzeichneten vertrag zurücktreten
darf macht hat sich bisher noch nicht
weiter geäußert und auch twitter hat
seine angestellten angewiesen nicht zum
thema zu twittern 1 aber dürfte
feststehen
twitter wird sich am montag
wahrscheinlich im freien fall befinden
wir schätzen zur börseneröffnung
25 bis 30 der druck wird groß sein denn
es war maske der die aktie stabil hielt
maske will sich zurückziehen ab montag
wird man sehen wie es mit ihm weitergeht
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
heinz wolf
lankas präsident rajapaksa will nach den
heftigen protesten
zurücktreten offenbar soll der schritt
am mittwoch erfolgen auch sein
premierminister hat angeboten sein amt
niederzulegen
zuvor hatten demonstranten den amtssitz
des präsidenten gestürmt sie machen ihn
und seine regierung für eine der
schwersten wirtschaftlichen krisen des
landes verantwortlich in sri lanka ist
hochverschuldet lebensmittel treibstoff
und medikamente sind seit monaten knapp
[Musik]
us-außenminister blinken hat china
erneut aufgefordert im ukraine krieg
position zu beziehen und die russische
aggression zu verurteilen
nach einem treffen mit seinem
chinesischen amtskollegen war nie am
rande der g20 konferenz auf bali sagte
blinken dieser wirklich ein moment in
dem man aufstehen müsse um die
aggression zu verurteilen und von
russland zu fordern den krieg zu beenden
nach dem mordanschlag auf japans
früheren regierungschef aber hat es
beileidsbekundungen aus aller welt
gegeben und vor dem krankenhaus in dem
abel seinen schussverletzungen erlegen
war bildeten sich schlangen von trauern
der geständige attentäter soll laut
japanischen medienberichten aus hass auf
eine religiöse gruppierung mit einer
angeblichen verbindung zu habe gehandelt
haben
in bayreuth hat es einen mutmaßlich
rechtsextremen angriffe auf einen
lokalpolitiker gegeben ein mann soll den
spd-politiker hallen castelen erst
rassistisch beleidigt und ihm dann ins
gesicht geschlagen haben die polizei hat
inzwischen einen 35-jährigen
tatverdächtigen festgenommen
steigende corona zahlen und viele kranke
mitarbeiter belasten etwa die hälfte der
intensivstationen in deutschen kliniken
das sagte der präsident der intensiv und
notfallmedizin marx der funke
mediengruppe zwar sei die versorgung von
notfallpatienten überall gesichert
zahlreiche operationen müssten aber
bereits verschoben werden
nicht nur die akute belastung der
krankenhäuser macht sorgen sondern auch
langfristige folgen für gesellschaft und
gesundheitswesen noch gibt es zu wenig
gesicherte erkenntnisse über das
phänomen longo wird klar ist aber dass
saft zwei ähnliche manch andere
viruserkrankungen langzeit folgen haben
kann bis hin zu schweren chronischen
erkrankungen darunter patienten die sich
zuvor als kerngesund jung und sportlich
beschrieben und seit ihrer corona
infektion nicht mehr auf die beine
kommen wen es trifft und wie viele ist
noch unklar die
weltgesundheitsorganisation schätzt dass
es mindestens zehn prozent sind für die
krone nicht nach zwei drei wochen vorbei
ist
mediziner hoffen hier auf neue
medikamente
berichtet sibylle bassler
andreas winter ist verzweifelt zweimal
hatte sich der 37 jährige mit corona
angesteckt er leidet unter den
spätfolgen atemnot schwindel
magen-darm-beschwerden vergesslichkeit
jeder tag sei eine qual so der
familienvater
ich weiß gar nicht wie oft sich zum
blutleeren waren bei den
unterschiedlichsten ärzten also
schlussendlich war dann die aussage ja
das ist lang kobelt aber wir wissen
nicht wie wir ihnen helfen können seit
kurzem nimmt er an einer studie der
uniklinik erlangen teil in umfangreichen
untersuchungen gehen die ärzte den
ursachen seiner erkrankung nach ein
wesentlicher baustein die analyse seines
bluts blutzellen von kugel patienten
scheinen weniger elastisch können den
sauerstoff vermutlich schlechter durch
die blutbahnen transportieren
müdigkeit abgeschlagenheit weil wir
geben falls die roten blutzellen nicht
mehr durch die feinsten kapillaren
passen und ihre aufgabe nicht mehr
erfüllen können eine weitere station der
test seiner kognitiven fähigkeiten was
sind die gründe für seine beschwerden
hat das virus je seinen körper verlassen
hat das organ schäden verursacht oder
spielt sein immunsystem verrückt
das ziel ist dass wir aus den
untersuchung verschiedene puzzlestücke
zusammen gesammelt und daraus dann ein
bild generieren und die entsprechenden
therapie den patienten raten bei winter
scheinen körpereigene eiweißstoffe
seinen organismus anzugreifen
nicht jeder long kubik patient leidet
daran ob dieser prozess von alleine
aufhört man weiß es nicht was dabei
helfen könnte ein medikament dass diese
fehlsteuerung ausschaltet und das
existiert bereits bc 007 vor einem jahr
mit guten ergebnissen in erlangen
angewandt ist das medikament noch immer
nicht zugelassen warum nicht ich glaube
dass dieses medikament sehr
vielversprechend ist aber wir können da
keine politischen vorgaben machen
sondern es muss bewertet werden durch
die fachgesellschaften tatsache ist dass
es kaum alternativen zu geben scheint
und das ist bitter so der infektiologe
clemens gentner man muss kritisch
hinterfragen ob es nicht auch sinnvoll
gewesen wäre notfall zu lassen
auszusprechen um eben auch den weg in
der pandemie zu kürzen und andreas
winter für ihn heißt es geduld haben den
zustand der verzweiflung aushalten wo
man sich jeden abend fragt wann endet es
endlich und will einfach dieses leben zu
vorbilder haben andreas winter ist einer
von etwa zwei millionen menschen in
deutschland die unter longkou witt
leiden
zum sport an diesem samstag helene
regina aus kasachstan hat das finale
beim tennisturnier in wimbledon gewonnen
in drei sätzen gegen uns ja boer aus
tunesien formel 1 weltmeister max
verstappen hat das sprintrennen in
spielberg österreich gewonnen vor schale
claire und carlos sainz und verstappen
startet damit morgen auch von der pole
position in den großen preis von
österreich
die lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 4 19 23 40
41 43 superzahl 6 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de grund im zf text auf seite 55 7
die wetteraussichten morgen scheint am
oberrhein meist die sonne sonst gibt es
zahlreiche wolken und vereinzelt schauer
im norden weht ein lebhafter
nordwestwind
die temperatur steigt auf 16 bis 25 grad
am montag ist es oft noch bewölkt am
dienstag ab dienstag überwiegt der
sonnenschein und es wird wärmer am
mittwoch werden im südwesten 35 grad
erreicht das war von uns anschließen
samstagabend und die nächste heute
express gibt es am 0 45 auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]